Vsauce Kevin here until robots render me
and everyone else with a job obsolete or
make us more human than we've ever been
humans have been working for a long time
we work the soil we work at jobs we work
on homework we hate going to work the
work can also fulfill us some of us work
to live and others live to work but
should robots do all the work for us
where did the modern idea of work come
from and is it natural in the
Paleolithic era our human ancestors were
hunters and gatherers they roamed the
world surviving on natural resources for
over two million years working to
improve their lives very slowly along
the way like by cooking meat in a fire
to make it easier to chew and digest or
observing time by marking lunar
movements on mammoth tusks and allows
put in effort - by migrating from
people's heads into their newly invented
clothes and evolving into the human body
louse which tells us that clothing maybe
about a hundred and seven thousand years
old and that lice are great history
teachers when the population eventually
blossomed to the point of making the
happy hunting-grounds lifestyle
unsustainable people needed to settle
down
we built simple homes instead of
depending on caves and started to plow
the ground we developed agriculture and
animal husbandry to take more control
over feeding ourselves many a goat was
consumed this newfound permanence meant
that we could store food surpluses
support larger families and develop
communities for the first time a smaller
number of people could work to feed the
population Neolithic humans could put
some of their time into new productive
pursuits like moving really really big
rocks humans began to realize the
potential and the necessity of working
together with each technological advance
we created new types of work and
relegated some tasks to history and
that's when it started to become obvious
that some work is better than others
proof of how much people like not having
to perform difficult unpalatable
professions goes back on
four thousand years the instruction of
dua Ketty a Middle Kingdom Egyptian text
in the form of a letter from a father to
his son extol the benefits of being a
scribe a new profession that rose to
prominence with the development of
writing the father disparages other more
physically taxing professions while
declaring that life as a scribe was the
best line of work during the ramesside
period of 1200 BC his instruction became
one of the most frequently used practice
texts for student scribes which means
ancient civilization homework was
literally motivation for avoiding
certain jobs language evolved to
describe professions and work but it
wasn't until the mid 1500s that we had
the most recognizable word defines our
role and participation in that system
job job in in Middle English meant to
jab or Peck a small action that's part
of a larger effort which is why a job is
just a piece of the whole that whole
being work often someone else's work the
word employment and tangle as an
employee you're caught in the snare of
your job and it came to define who we
were
occupational last names like carpenter
Baker Eisenhower and Cabrera identified
a person's position in society by their
profession they did one job for so long
that it permanently branded their family
a job became a legacy that dictated your
path through life sometimes with heavy
consequences to ensure future work for
their families metal grinders during the
industrial revolution denied safer
working conditions because if they lived
longer there'd be fewer job openings for
their sons fear of other humans limiting
job availability soon gave way to the
panic of machines eliminating jobs
altogether the spinning jenny
single-handedly wiped out a job that it
existed for thousands of years spinning
thread a job so ingrained in human
culture that the term spinster was
coined to describe a woman who spent her
whole life spinning
read without marrying invented in 1764
the spinning jenny made the weaving
process so efficient that people were
afraid and take their jobs
spinners broke into inventor James
Hargreaves house and destroyed his
equipment to try to halt progress and
protect their livelihoods decades later
English textile workers called Luddites
banded together to destroy labor
economizing technology for fear of being
forced out of work economists now use
the term Luddite fallacy to explain the
fear that advances in technology will
lead to structural unemployment what
really happens is that technological
advancement causes industry-wide
production costs to fall which lowers
the competitive price and increases the
supply and in theory leads to more input
labor that becomes irrelevant shifts
into new areas and our goods get cheaper
and better as our standard of living
Rises in 1973 it took the average
American 97.1 hours of labour to afford
a color TV more than two weeks of
full-time work by 2009 it took only two
days to afford a slimmer lighter more
energy-efficient high-definition TV
we're spending less time working to
procure food and meeting basic survival
needs but we haven't become lazy we
freed ourselves up to solve other
problems we're beating back Belphegor
the chief demon of sloth and one of the
seven princes of Hell Belphegor was
described by 16th century German witch
hunter Peter bins field as using the
promise of innovation and ingenious
inventions to lure humans into laziness
the fear was that work reducing
technology would free up too much time
and allow evil to creep into humanity
however lifespans and standards of
living have consistently improved with
each passing generation which means by
today's standards Peter bins field could
have hunted witches more efficiently and
for longer with the advancement of steam
engine
leading to electricity leading to
computers leading to robots it's leading
to the end of many jobs a natural
function of human progression that has
happened over and over from the printing
press eliminating scribes to telephone
switchboard operators being replaced by
complex telephone and data exchange
systems the equipment that makes this
service possible is among the most
complex that man has ever devised
humanity needs technology because human
labour can only accomplish so much it's
why large animals like horses were first
used to make up for the shortcomings of
human muscle but all animals have limits
as CGP grey illustrates in his humans
need not apply video the horse
population plummeted after the advent of
machine power but we still use the term
horse power as a measurement of a
machine's output the horse power unit
proved very useful what was able to tell
mine owners and businessmen exactly what
size engine would be needed to replace
the horses they had been using
inventions help humans overcome our
shortcomings writing was developed to
make up for the limitations of memory
and technological advances allow us to
use our labor more specifically the
Industrial Revolution marked the first
time in human history that the majority
of people were put to work doing
specialized jobs prior to that
specialization was the work of the elite
scribes copying text architects hired
for public works projects court jesters
juggling batons now if you want to spend
your life reviewing seagull poops
simulators there's a job for that but
the reasons robots will replace humans
and many labor sectors are the same
reasons that Scottish engineer James
nasmyth preferred self-acting machines
and tools over skilled workers in the
1800's they never got drunk their hands
never shook from excess they were never
absent from work they did not strike for
wages they were unfailing in their
accuracy and regularity
are more dependable and consistent but
machines and robots aren't human and
their continued implementation in the
workforce means our humanity may be the
most valuable attribute we have when
robots are performing mundane tasks more
and more people will be involved in
uniquely human jobs markets built around
human connection and collective
experiences we're on that path right now
the amount of hours humans work per
lifetime are dramatically lower than
ever and a 2015 US Department of Labor
reports stated that the average number
of jobs held by a baby-boomer from age
18 to 48 was eleven point seven through
most of human history we worked
constantly at one thing and now we're
working less and doing many different
jobs with greater flexibility increased
opportunities to work from home and work
less have improved the family dynamic by
allowing parents to spend more time
raising their children if we automate
the systems that fulfill our most basic
survival needs will it finally allow us
the freedom to spend our time the way we
want
Studs Terkel x' landmark book working
includes interviews with 130 people
about their jobs many felt their work
gave their lives daily meaning to
accompany the earned daily bread
but others felt trapped I'm a machine
says the spot welder I'm cage says the
bank teller I'm a mule says the steel
worker a monkey can do what I do says
the receptionist I'm an object as the
high-fashion model but from the upper
crust white-collar to the lowest paying
blue-collar workers one phrase is used
repeatedly I'm a robot and as always
thanks for watching
we know we are somewhere in the middle
of a period of unprecedented economic
change for those of us who view history
as a fascinating spectacle the prospect
of the coming quarter century is
exhilarating it is as if we were
privileged not only to see but to
participate in centuries of development
telescoped into a brief span it is not
too early to train your sights on this
prospect right now
they move throw it all over again
no God Allah
you